بنعم صوت مستخدم وتويتر لتنحي الماسك من
رئاسه شركه توتر التي يمتلكها بعد ان وضع
الملياردار الامريكي مصيره في ايدي
المشاركين في هذا التصويت ونشر ماسك
تغريده كتب فيها هل علي التنحي عن رئاسه
تويتر هذا هو السؤال مع احتمالين هما نعم
وكلا متعهدا بالالتزام بالنتيجه اسفرت
نتيجه هذا التصويت عن موافقه
57.5% صوت بنعم و 42.5 صوتوا
اذا مشاهدينا في استطلاع هذا الاستطلاع
الذي شارك فيه اكثر من 17 مليون شخص نشر
الملياردير الذي كان اغنى رجل في العالم
هذا الاستطلاع بعد اقراره على ما يبدو
بانه ارتكب خطا من خلال منعه مستخدمين
تويتر من الترويج لحساباتهم على منصات
اجتماعيه منافسه غرد قائلا سيحصل تصويت
على تغييرات كبرى في قواعد الاستخدام
اعتذر لن يتكرر ذلك واثر ماسك الجده
المرات عده منذ تواليه رئاسه تويتر قبل
السبع قليله بما يشمل صرفه للكثير من
العمال في التويتر اعاده بعض الحسابات
حسابات اليمين المتطرف وحجب حسابات صحفيه
بعد فتره وجيزه من تواليه لرئاسه المنصه
اعلن ان التوتر ستتقادى ثماني دولارات
شهريا مقابل توثيق الحساب لكنه الطره الى
تعليق خطه وتر بلو بعد توفيق كثير من
الحسابات المزيفه ثم اعيد العمل بهذه
الخدمه مؤخرا في الرابع من نوفمبر قلم
ماسك ان الشركه تخسر اربعه ملايين دولار
في اليوم كم استغنت تويتر عن نصفي موظفيها
البالغ عددهم
7,500 موظف
[موسيقى]